[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we tried to get everyone's names to the
media however before we start speaking
everyone will introduce themselves and
who they are I spell their names I'll
start my name is Li merit l ee m ER RI
TT I'm a civil rights attorney for the
family you're gonna be hearing from
members of the community of Fort Worth
you'll be hearing from the family of who
they affectionately call it a Jefferson
and and we'll be taking some time to
answer some questions for you all I want
to go ahead and dispel the myth that
this is somehow a one-off that this was
just you know a bad luck incident for my
otherwise sound Department the Fort
Worth police department is on basically
one of the deadliest police departments
in the United States they're in need of
serious systemic reform we are asking
that the federal government comes in the
Department of Justice comes in and takes
a heavy conscious look at the policies
and procedures that allow something like
this tragedy to happen this was a
wellness call it's beyond me to begin to
understand what kind of police force
response to a wellness call with the
equivalent of SWAT this department and
their officers violated not only the
rights of obtain Jefferson and her
family but they just made common-sense
mistakes they passed an open door they
failed to announce themselves they
passed a second open door they failed to
announce themselves they creeped around
the back of the apartment and entered a
closed gate they didn't have probable
cause at this point from what the
neighbor told them
Tevan into that property they began
creeping around and it created a deadly
situation the idea that they have
blasted images of a firearm across the
Internet
is obscene of course a family owns a
firearm of course firearms are used to
protect individuals from predators
prowling about their property that's
only common sense they created a deadly
situation and they responded in the way
that is not unique to the city of Fort
Worth in the last six months they've had
tens officer-involved shootings 77
officer-involved deaths that's more than
most nations for one a single city in
Texas it represents a serious problem
that must be addressed so of course this
family is calling for the firing of this
officer that's benign that's the least
we could we should expect they're
calling for this officer to be
vigorously prosecuted to be
appropriately sentence that prosecution
the investigation should be handled by
someone other than the Fort Worth police
department specifically the Department
of Justice the FBI a worst case scenario
the the the local sheriff's department
anyone other than the city of Fort Worth
was clearly incompetent to investigate
it cells should be called in we expect
this to happen immediately this happened
Saturday why this man is not in
handcuffs right now is it's a source of
continued agitation for this family and
for this community and it must be
addressed in a moment you'll hear from
Cory Hughes who was an activist and a
member of the Fort Worth community and
then you heard directly from the family
of Jefferson
[Music]
[Music]
just for the correct spelling of my name
it is co ry last name Hughes h ug h es
the the reality is I've had the
unfortunate responsibility of sitting in
front of these cameras and sitting next
to families that have lost loved ones by
the handles of police officers all too
often as a member of the community of
Fort Worth as someone that has taken the
responsibility to be a voice for my
community I want to set the record
straight that we're not looking for a
30-day suspension we're not looking for
a slap on the wrist we're not looking
for what seems to be status quo is that
the people that we hire to serve and
protect us when one of their own
violates the community it seems like
they do more of trying to serve and
protect their own so what we're looking
for is for this officer not only to be
fired but we're demanding that this
officer be charged as well like the
criminal that he is it's a sad
commentary in this day and age that
someone could be sitting in their home
playing a video game with a family
member and not be safe that when someone
calls the police for wellness check then
instead of them checking on how well she
is days later we're here talking about
the fact that an officer took her life
it's unacceptable we're demanding
justice we're demanding that the mayor
and the city officials don't sweep this
under the rug we're not going to allow
you to this life mattered this life
matter this family matters and we're
demanding justice and we're not gonna
wait we demand justice now thank you
it's going to be the brother about Tiana
Jefferson and I'll let him introduce
himself
my name is Darius car I am currently
stationed in San Diego I said my country
so that's twelve years and that time
I've been trained and taught the
pre-planned responses to everything you
do everything you're trained about
there's all a way to do things but when
you don't do it the way you've been
trained or you've been taught you have
to ask for that you have been trained
you know better see that past for
nothing you took man I need the part of
me someone comes in invested the whole
incident for speedy 1090 biscuit
themselves US Navy is allowed to do it
they should not really well this man
murdered someone you should be arrested
and we want to continue to Apple calls
and be clear to this family standing in
solidarity that Fort Worth needs to
recuse itself from this uh from this
investigation they need to bring in an
outside agency they need to make sure
this officer was treated like any other
criminal suspect and our criminal
justice system the next person that
you're going to hear from is the sister
of amber I'm sorry the sister of Tay and
her name is amber amber amplifier I'm
her one of her older sisters we're 11
months apart we grew up together the
last time I spoke to my sister was last
Saturday she came to the hospital and
playing on when I was recovering from a
major heart surgery she came brought me
food she brought me a new cell phone she
talked about how this weekend actually
was the weekend that she and my older
sister were planning to take the boys to
the fair and asked me what I want back
considering she knew I wasn't going to
be able to walk the fair park my sister
[Music]
the relationship she has with my sons
is undescribable sometimes people think
that their heart kids and not mine
she helped Sonia everyday to get ready
for spinning because my mother wasn't
capable of doing it
she wrote out of schedule so that he
could be organized she helped him
understand that he had to be responsible
for putting on his clothes picking out
his clothes and getting ready on time to
leave for the day those were things that
my mom did for him so she helped him
become more independent and
self-sufficient my son who was there to
witness then you would think that you
know he was show some type of sadness or
emotions but the first time I actually
got to see him and pick him up from a
facility for children the first thing he
told me was he was sad and I asked him
why was he said and he told me because
the police had killed his has shot his
son and at that time I knew nothing
about that so he was the one who
actually told me what had what happened
but at this time he's my motivation and
he's my biggest encouraging in the
middle of night when I'm crying he wakes
up and tell me to breathe in my nose and
held my mouth he holds me he hugs me and
these are the things I should be doing
for him but he's not reacting in that
manner he's helping me to be strong and
I believe that's because my sister had a
big
the next person that you're gonna hear
from she's prepared a statement I'm on
allow her to come around her name is
Ashley Carr older
good morning everyone
my name is Ashley par I was a tatyana
Jefferson's oldest sister I'm here to
read a statement for the family
so that we can all be on one Accord an
art of a moral universe is a long one
but it bends towards justice Martin
Luther King our family first would like
to thank the thousands who called who
sent messages who reached out via social
media offering words of encouragement
and condolences we appreciate your
powerful solitude with us as we go
through this unbelievable time of shock
and sorrow secondly our family would
like you to know more about this
beautiful soul on Tatyana Jefferson she
was a smart ambitious kind person with a
nurturing spirit she was a graduate of
Xavier University with a Bachelors of
Science degree in mathematics and I mean
that's me in biology and was committed
to furthering her education she was a
hard worker where her co-workers saw her
as a person of being of a person of full
integrity she was loved she loved her
family so much that at the age of 28 she
decided to move into our our mother's
home to help her as her health was
declined honor integrity commitment and
service these are the attributes of
Tatiana Jefferson any parents would be
proud to call her a daughter any sibling
will be proud to call her a sister any
employer would be proud to call her an
employee
any neighborhood would be proud to have
her as a neighbor and any city would be
proud to have her as a citizen and yet
in the early mornings of October 11 2019
she was simply going on along with her
life living a law-abiding the citizens
peaceful lives and she was killed by
reckless act of a Fort Worth police
officer
there is simply no justification for his
actions she was enjoying a life in her
home where no one would have expected it
to be her life to be in harm's leg
especially not at the hands of a civil
servants who had taken the oath to serve
and protect our family now is asking the
city of Fort Worth to exhibit the
pretty and bring the federal government
in to investigate to be committed to a
swift and appropriate prosecution serve
the entire community of Fort Worth by
training your officers to execute the
responses to appropriate situations in
closing we demand justice for a tatiana
through an independent Darrell and
transparent process the family of a
Tatyana Jefferson and the world eagerly
awaits your response to this tragedy it
is imperative that your response bends
towards justice
thank you are you next gonna hear from
the sister of Yolanda
whose mother was the mother she couldn't
be with us today because she is
hospitalized and she's recovering from
injuries that that predated this
incident that those injuries are the
reason that Tay moved in with her mom
and she was at this address because she
was helping her back and forth to the
hospital and helping her around the home
she wants to be here and stand with her
family we have been back and forth to
the hospital with her every night
keeping her in the loop she is of course
heart broken and our system wants to
speak on her behalf
oldest sister I'm speaking of on her
behalf today because she could not be
here as you have heard her health is
declining and I've heard of the
allegations of mr. Marquis Jefferson is
what I want to address claiming to be
her biological father which he is not
nor has he ever had legal custody of her
we have not as a family heard from mr.
Jefferson and if he cares to reach out
to us we would be more than happy to
address his concerns and I want you to
know that the GoFundMe page that is
family approved today's legal family and
I thank everyone for their outreach for
their giving and for the love that they
have shown us today all right thank you
so much
and we have we've asked you all not to
direct questions to the family I'm sure
you all have some for them but I and
Cory Hughes or some of the pastors and
attorneys who are working on the case
with me are happy to answer some
questions
we appreciate that the Fourth Police
Department released this video
immediately that's the kind of
transparency that we need to get to the
bottom of these cases however they threw
in an unrelated according to their
statement the photograph of a firearm
and in order to I guess impute some bad
act or blame on the victim itself that
was not necessarily to circulate and
that's more like the Fort Worth that we
know we we when we look at the video and
we see it was several officers prowling
around the property literally crawling
whispering as if they were conducting
some sort of clandestine abstraction
it's absurd when you know what the call
is
they finally really see the emergency
call yesterday which I'm sorry the
non-emergency call yesterday which was a
neighbor who was concerned about an
ailing woman across the street he he he
gave no indication that he believes that
a crime was taking place that he was in
fear for his life or the safety of the
members in that home or the community he
said he saw some doors open and so to
see them again pass those open doors
without announcing themselves to park
around the corner so that no one if they
happen to be near the home could know
who they were and then and then to
escalate the situation as they enter the
property it's it's it's just
unacceptable yes
I will not charge this officer and
perhaps not do it experience experience
tells us that law enforcement can of
officers law enforcement departments
aren't competent to investigate
themselves we've seen over and over and
over again where they make
recommendations for additional training
or suspensions or that nothing happens
to them they they've already began to
lay out their defense in this case they
obviously have a dog in the fight or
they wouldn't have released a picture of
the firearm to the public but they're
trying to make a case for what we hear
far too often that this that this
officer perceived a threat and I in
reacted according to his training they
violated their training over and over
again they they interestingly enough cut
off the video immediately after the shot
I would love to hear the rest of the
conversation from the other officers
because this was completely uncalled for
and it probably was one officer there
was some common sense that chastised
this rookie who had no business so as a
part of SRT team an elite unit in the
first place so
probably the rules but I'll let him
answer that that's my service u.s. Navy
yeah service is a little big for our
family we we want to get back to this
world we want to make it a better place
I probably served my country I'm gonna
do it for instant my life okay any other
questions I answer prizes me with how
much he recalls Zion is going to start
counseling this week because we don't
know the emotional trauma the
psychological trauma that seeing
something like this can have on an
eight-year-old he was present the entire
time he never left the room he saw he he
and his auntie K experienced the fear of
someone prowling in the backyard his
auntie Tate did not allow him to check
the windows she checked herself I asked
myself what would have happened if that
little boy went to the window instead of
his auntie he saw her when she fell and
he has found a way to maintain more
composure than the Fort Worth police
department he still offers his mother in
his family consoling
he encourages his mother when he hears
her crying in the middle of the night
she tells me he says what did that
remember what I told you
I guess he's giving you some words of
encouragement those words of
encouragement a good
just breathe through your nose I'll
chill out so he's he's learned coping
mechanisms in school for a high stress
situation and in any and he he
encourages his mother to to try some of
those out to get her through this
difficult time it was a fall evening for
those of you all who live in the
dallas-fort Worth area was one of the
first this week was one of the first
chills that we've had for a relatively
warm fall and so they opened the doors
and I when they allowed to allow the
breeze to flow through the house and
those two stayed up all night playing
I've said hello before I was wrong they
were up all night playing call of duty
Tatyana is a gamer I talked to you on it
is a is a gamer
she loved video games and she beat her
brother a few times a night she she she
loved playing with her nephew they did
that all night from sunset to until the
time that they lost track of time around
2 or 3 o'clock in the morning when they
heard someone problen around in the
bushes
no that's not out of character character
at all now we understand why the name
you
on this check he thought maybe that she
had been released from the hospital and
had another traumatic events and she
possibly may have needed help so the
family prepared a statement and that's
all they're gonna say about her for the
moment it was a legally owned firearm
that tey is of course in Texas allowed
to keep inside of her home but she also
had a license to carry I haven't heard
anything about the render at the
rendering of a Montana said she perished
on the scene but this family has learned
and will wait to hear back from the
medical examiner about where she was
struck and what kind of steps were
taking to try to save her life this I'm
sorry this was a tight-knit community
people knew each other
and it's scary to see the Fort Worth
Police Department's response to this
community we believe that the the fact
this was a black neighborhood had it had
a role in their response to it the fact
that they showed up with SWAT as opposed
to your friendly neighborhood top but
this was one of the nicest houses on the
block
this was it this was what you would
expect in the situation's for law
enforcement to go over to the neighbors
today he made a call do you want to come
over with us this is what American
communities should expect the black
communities get the opposite this is not
the first time that a black person in
Fort Worth called law enforcement for
help and was brutalized in fact
represent - Jacqueline Craig who called
the neighbor called law enforcement for
help and instead have her and her
teenage daughter's brutalized on
national this is a pattern for that
department and it seems common when
dealing with people of African America
we will be there my office I am a
representative from my office will be
there the only thing that we expected
here is that this officer is immediately
terminated and that they were accusing
themselves from the investigation that
they've asked for an outside department
to come in and take over investigating
not only this officers actions but the
department's practices this is this is
as a problematic Police Department I
don't expect them to acknowledge that
themselves but they just lost the police
chief who was suing them based on their
what he has alleged is race-based
discrimination this is a police
department that has been been mentioned
there's been ten incidents like this 10
police officer involved shootings in the
last six months was just more most than
most nations after years and years there
needs to be steps taken to radically
reformed the city of Fort Worth chief
Joel Fitzgerald held himself out as a
reformer and he in and he at least again
held himself out of still is hoping to
make change this family the community is
less concerned with figureheads we don't
believe that you fit the chief
Fitzgerald is is a savior but there
needs to be policies and set in place
training set in place there needs to be
radical reforms in that department
if chief Fitzgerald is the person to
lead to charge for or I should say for
mercy Fitzgerald is the person to lead
the charge for reform then absolutely
but it's not about putting a black face
on it it's about actual change
here's to be a rage growing around my
social media
rage concern investment is the
appropriate response to someone being
killed in their home it should be
sustained until things change and it
should remain this should be outrageous
there should be so many people invested
in this that they keep sustained
pressure on the city of Fort Worth until
it radically changes and so this family
is outraged and hurting they're greatly
appreciative of the community of folks
from all over the world who have reached
out to see what is going on in Fort
Worth but we need it to be sustained and
so I on behalf this family we ask that
those people who are outraged that they
channel their anger that they direct it
towards policy makers that they directed
towards substantive changes that can
take place all right thank you all so
much